If you walk up to typical computer today, you're
likely to find several applications open. One for listening
to music. One for playing your video game. A
web browser displaying information on some ancient culture from some
remote corner of the world. And a messaging application
for connecting with friends, and so on. How is it
possible for a single device to do all these
things, and moreover, do them all at the same time?
How can all these diverse applications, written by
different programmers who don't even know each other,
coordinate? Who's in charge here? The answer of
course is the operating system. Hello and welcome to
CS6210 Advanced Operating Systems. My name is Kishore
Ramachandran and I'll be taking you on a
journey to understand the role played by the
operating system in providing the rich user experience afforded
to modern applications, the modern computers. And
along the way, I'll highlight the symbiotic relationship
between hardware and software that makes it
possible for the computer and the operating system
to provide the rich user experience to
please you. Operating systems have evolved over time.
In this course we will see all the advances that have been made in the
operating system that has led to the
state of the art in operating systems today.
Covering a variety of platforms, from cell
phones to multi-core, to parallel systems, to distributive
computing and cloud computing. In part one
of this introductory lesson, my goal is to
primarily talk about the power of abstraction.
That will lay the foundation for the rest
of the introductory lesson, which will
include an overview of the hardware resources
managed by the operating system. The operating
system functionality that is expected, and the
abstractions in an operating system for
managing the hardware resources. By the end
of the lesson, we will be ready to discuss the structure of operating systems.